if you want to watch some porn but
you're dumb and easily confused do your
best to get off on the xxx franchise
[Music]
porno star catch the films Vin Diesel
makes between fasts and Riddick's and
the films Ice Cube makes between Fridays
and are we there yet as you rock out to
a spy trilogy that asks what if James
Bond had twice the comitia his gadgets
were designed for sex criminals and his
mission was to sneak into Ozzfest while
wearing progressively larger codes dude
looks like an ostrich giving birth when
danger lurks beneath the sexy dance club
hooker mechanic shop or off-the-grid
jungle rave from jungle rivers
off-the-grid America will need a new
breed of secret agent and by secret
I mean world-famous celebrity Xander
cage this is crazy
snowboard motorbike everything you're
awesome with a neck tat of their agency
and won't hesitate to out themselves if
they think it would get them laid I'm a
secret agent I work for the NSA it would
be like recruiting an international
soccer star to go undercover
oh they did that too
Vin Diesel is Sandra Cage a rebel with
an obnoxious attention to detail
stockbroker over here reading the
Financial Times on a Sunday morning the
lady that was running to go figure this
rebel is so rebellious he rebelled
against Authority join the rebels then
rebel against the rebels to protect the
authorities right to be rebelled against
I think just don't get him confused with
Dominic Toretto because while this tank
top trunk also loves muscle cars mumble
growling citizen and my vocabulary and
surrounding himself with multi-ethnic
world celebrities to maximize global
ticket sales Xander has an upsetting
slack-jawed horny face you know close
your mouth Finn please
did you enjoy that no but when you've
got a script to dump for even been
diesel it's time to look for someone
with even more attitude more attitude
and bring in the new xxx
Darius stone he doesn't do extreme
sports more problems motion for love the
ladies if you need anything anything you
know how about some fries in the shape
but he does hit people with his elbows a
lot
plus he's got a little bunny hop when he
runs oh it's so cute
are you ready for action
but chug a Red Bull four sequences that
give the finger to gravity and logic
where cars become trains bikes becomes
surfboards serving trays become
skateboards skis become dirt skis and
just when it seems like all hope is lost
I'll ramp will emerge to launch the
heroes into glory take it from xxx kids
anything is a ramp if you put your mind
to it
[Music]
what the hell you think you're doing
building around so enjoy a ridiculous
franchise that somehow overcomes its
clunky dialogue yet Cronk eggs come on
still get Prague with this word
embarrassing needle drops
and parade of stereotypes everything's
alright we did enough worker because
enough time has passed that we're
getting nostalgic for the early
two-thousands era of new metal and
nipple tattoos
crank that crazy town and pass the
go-gurt I wonder how my new pants are
doing oh they're all dead
story bong James bong hair today gone
tomorrow a leather-clad female double
agent dr. daniela bad guy from speed -
Donny yes and Tony yeah Ruby Tuesday's
Tony Coletti a paycheck your two
favorite PlayStation games you ain't
nothin but a hound dog crashing all the
time but chat a No Limit album covers
1996 to 2000 and iced cube Mission
Impossible oh do we want to drop another
Mouse in the snake pit do we want to
send our own snake and let him crawl it
ok boss just make sure you pick ground
shipping this time
hello ladies come out to the coast we'll
get together have a few laughs I'm a man
of substance dorky chicks like you
turned me on to this is your alarm voice
wake up immediately this is a ringtone
ring ring ring ring